i feel good that's true we're thrilled
about our next guest that's drew
barrymore that's all she does is make
you feel good the drew barrymore show is
returning for season number three today
congratulations mrs barrymore in the
season premiere the emmy nominated host
sits down with her ex boyfriend actor
justin long they talk about staying
friends this is a preview
i feel like we've been through so much
together too you know i feel like when
we used to like talk and facetime i was
always like you know i've really grown
up justin like i always wanted to prove
to you
what a different person i was than when
we dated you were the best we had so
much it's fun no i know but we were you
know
more hedonistic
a little more immature
you know we would get together we would
break up you know there was chaos it was
hell of fun fun chaos oh yeah yeah well
it's yeah most hedonism is fun that's
what i said the drew barrymore show is
produced by cbs media ventures that's a
division of paramount global drew
barrymore as you see joins us now living
color in the family in the family i
would love to know how this came about
drew because most people are not
interested in talking to their exes
on camera so did you call him and say
you know i'd really like you to come to
the show this is what i want to talk
about because clearly it's very
emotional which makes me think you guys
had a decent breakup or not so decent
what is hedonistic euphemism for yeah
because justin and i we did we had so
much fun we were together at a time of
our lives where the stakes were low we
weren't thinking about marriage and
children we were just having fun
and so you called him and said i want
you to come on to talk yeah and it just
sort of organically happened and you
know how that who you premier your show
with is such a big deal in the industry
and season one i was like i want cameron
and lucy to come on yes and so for
cameron diaz
yeah from charlie zhang exactly i was
like these are people who are meaningful
to me and sometimes i want to be in awe
of the person i can meet people i've
never met before i can meet old friends
but i think there's something about
taking the opportunity of this show to
make it a personal journey yeah and i
think you know i can't wait to see the
conversation between the two and the
tears came midway through the interview
it was not the initial we were just
laughing and then
he said something that really triggered
the emotion to come on and i say at the
beginning of the show in the cold open
like never miss an opportunity to
champion your ex which is a play on the
rain video that i did
and people made fun of you about the
rain video did you care oh i mean i
loved it i watched stephen colbert he
was like what an adorable psychotic
break and i'm like you can't oh yeah
well he's not wrong i mean i'm from
seattle and i love the rain so there's
nothing wrong with this i wasn't having
a psychotic break but you know in comedy
i should say all's fair in love and
comedy
in life i mean true i thought it was
your joy for life it was i was just you
know i i know we overthink things so
much we get so uptight that's a part of
the new look i'm sporting is this is a
very new look we all commented it came
out okay i was here with you guys when
we launched and gail you said something
you said there's a graveyard you know
with headstones of talk shows
i'm in the graveyard drew so i'm very
familiar and i think that's good company
so listen if i end up in that graveyard
i'll be i want my headstone right next
to yours and
you know you when you said that when i
was doing season one we were in the
pandemic height september 2020. i knew
that the world was changing i was
uptight it was a scary time but you're
not uptight you are not uptight and i
always think it's hard that's yeah i
know i wasn't wishing
a unique gig and i feel like season
three we've gotten here it's time for me
to loosen up a little
we've never been a show that had a
tremendous amount of confidence for how
long we would last and i'm like i like
admitting that too i'm so sick of like
yeah this is easy we got this i'm like
no these are big hurdles to figure out
let's do this together
and we love how emotionally tapped in
you are and we are looking forward to
season three
make sure you check out the premiere
because it's going down drew barrymore
thank you so much we appreciate you all
right today love you guys that'll do for
us see you guys later